Jean-Paul Palomeros bonjour vous êtes
ancien chef d'état-major de l'armée de
l'air ancien commandant suprême des
forces alliés de l'OTAN on entendait ce
soldat
ukrainien parler de probable piège
autour de ce retrait probable des Russes
de Carson puisqu'il n'est toujours pas
confirmé certains experts évoquent une
opération de déception qui vise donc à
tromper l'ennemi vous en pensez quoi
oh ça fait partie des opérations c'est
classique dans un conflit évidemment on
va pas afficher ses intentions à
l'adversaire il est probable que les
Russes vont rester quand même à Carson
ils vont se retrancher même dans le
Carson Carson c'était la grande victoire
russe c'était une capitale régionale
c'est aussi une défaite ukrainienne au
début du conflit il faut s'en souvenir
elle a été c'est une ville qui a été
prise finalement assez rapidement et
c'est une ville on ne cesse de répéter
qui est stratégique dont l'environnement
aussi est assez complexe environnement
géographique avec un barrage au nord qui
est tout à fait stratégique et avec des
différences de topologie je dirais qui
rendent le combat assez assez délicat
assez difficile que ce soit à l'ouest ou
à l'est du Nièvre on l'a bien compris
c'est une bataille rude longue c'est une
bataille de tranchées qui mobilise des
milliers de soldats
à sa mobilise des milliers de soldats ça
c'est sûr
et les Ukrainiens s'y préparent
visiblement mais d'un autre côté ils ne
veulent ils ne veulent pas monter à la
sauce si vous voulez c'est trancher
c'est pas ça leur tactique ils ont bien
compris que d'une part il ne pouvait pas
écraser Carson sous les bombes ça
c'était plutôt la méthode russe mais
évidemment ne peuvent pas le faire
vis-à-vis de leur citoyens vis-à-vis de
ceux qui restent à Carson il en reste
encore et puis d'un autre côté donc ils
emploient plutôt une stratégie que je
considère comme prudente mais efficace
il reste quand même des points clés
c'est une fine
ce qui va se passer au nord du côté du
barrage c'est important et puis deuxième
point est-ce qu'ils vont rentrer
effectivement dans des combats urbains
il y a pas tellement de solutions s'ils
veulent vraiment prendre la ville il y a
un moment ou l'autre il faudra rentrer
dans des combats urbains autant pour
essayer de le faire dans les meilleures
conditions parlons peut-être de ce
barrage donc de kakovka qui est situé en
amont d'une nièpre les
Ukrainiens affirment que les Russes
l'ont minées
sa destruction ça entraînerait une
inondation majeure de la région
ah oui ça c'est il y a pas d'autres
là-dessus c'est un très très gros
barrage et donc ça aura des tas
d'implication y compris d'après ce que
j'ai compris en tout cas sur la
refroidissement de la centrale ça
pourrait déjà mais au-delà effectivement
en aval ça va inondé en particulier
d'ailleurs plutôt la rive gauche sont où
sont les Russes aujourd'hui mais mais ça
aurait des conséquences dramatiques pour
cette région ce serait un peu la
politique de la terre inondée si je peux
m'exprimer ainsi ça peut être un réflexe
ou en tout cas une volonté russe de le
faire s'ils doivent vraiment quitter
cette ville ça serait désastreux est-ce
que les Russes ont déjà eu cette
stratégie ailleurs en Ukraine
il y a pas rien de se compare si vous
voulez il n'y a pas de situation
similaire en Ukraine pour l'instant on
n'a pas vu vraiment de politique de
terre brûlée mais en contrepartie on a
vu la politique de rasage en quelque
sorte de ville entière sous des bombes
enfin de villages entiers sous des
bombes donc
s'avancer sur ce que font les Russes ou
non c'est un pari délicat en tout cas
c'est une option qui ne peut absolument
pas être écarté en tout cas ce qui est
sûr c'est que les autorités prorus de
Kerson
ont ordonné au civils d'évacuer
immédiatement vers l'Est est-ce que l'on
connaît leur sort
ça s'appelle de la déportation ou il y
en a sans doute qui sont favorables qui
sont favorables parce que
contraint par et contraint et forcé par
cette guerre parce qu'ils doivent
survivre il faut se mettre à la place
des populations qui ont déjà vécu
l'invasion de personnes dans un premier
temps qui voit maintenant que les
Ukrainiens vont revenir donc voilà
si vous voulez il faut qu'ils arrivent à
vivre dans des conditions à peu près des
centres que ce soit sous le drapeau
russe ou ukrainien préféraient sans
doute que ça soit ukrainien mais faut se
mettre à la place de ces pauvres gens
je lisais que les Russes se mobilisaient
aussi pour empêcher les Ukrainiens de
traverser le niepre qui barre l'accès à
la péninsule de Crimée est-ce que les
Ukrainiens selon vous sont tentés
d'aller jusqu'à la péninsule et la
libérer elle qui a été annexée en 2014
alors ça c'est une question très
politique évidemment très très
stratégique qui se pose plus dans des
termes de positionnement de négociation
aujourd'hui que dans une réalité déjà
occupé préoccuper Carson stabiliser
cette région ça va être un sacré défi
pour les c'est un sacré défi pour les
Ukrainiens de la pensée que ils vont ils
vont pouvoir aller jusqu'en Crimée s'ils
le veulent s'il le souhaite ça a été
affiché effectivement par le président
zeninski il y a et puis que feront les
occidentaux dans cette situation ça
reste du domaine des hypothèques mais
d'ici là il y aura personne il y aura
l'hiver donc malheureusement on y verra
plus clair après après cette période
merci beaucoup Jean-Paul Palomeros
d'avoir nous avoir éclairé sur la
situation actuelle à Carson et en
Ukraine plus généralement